[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa con rosa pérez más de hoy
vamos a hablar con el tema que avanzaba
daniela hablándome en economía se juntan
estas dos crónicas para finalizar una y
abrir la otra la oferta y la un más para
comprar twitter en su integridad del
periodista clave es humana opina en la
revista de tecnología wire que el gestor
mox debería hacer hacer saltar las
alarmas porque éstos rosa pérez masdéu
feliz inicio de semana buenos días raúl
bien digamos que el periodista que
escribe este artículo está de acuerdo
con la afirmación que hizo él o más que
en la que dijo que twitter es lo más
parecido que tenemos a una ágora social
donde pueda compartir los distintos
puntos de vista que se encuentran en la
opinión y en el debate público sin
embargo el on mars dice dijo que los
directivos de twitter no eran capaces de
proteger la libertad de expresión en
esta red social lo que socava la
democracia
el periodista digamos está de acuerdo
con que twitter sea un ágora pública
socava la democracia pero no por los
mismos argumentos que el on mars porque
dice el on mars entiende por libertad de
expresión una relajación de las normas
de moderación de twitter según el on
mars
esta moderación debería estar solamente
limitada por las normas de libertad de
expresión de cada país lo que dice el
periodista sería terrible en el caso de
eeuu donde la primera enmienda protege
ciertos discursos del odio eso sí lo que
dice el periodista es que es peligroso
que twitter se ha convertido en esta
especie de ágora social o al menos que
lo consideramos lo más parecido que
tenemos a esto a un ágora social porque
al final está en manos de una empresa
privada y dice los periodistas de hecho
somos los culpables de haber convertido
twitter en esta falsa representación de
la opinión pública no porque dice es la
plataforma que usan tanto académicos
como políticos como personas de la
cultura
para entrar directamente en contacto con
la agenda mediática no dice los
periodistas hemos abusado y hemos creado
una super dependencia de esta red social
utilizándolo pues como medidor de la
opinión pública considerando por ejemplo
raúl esto lo hacemos no que un tweet
viral significa una gran preocupación
por un tema o digamos pasando horas y
horas en esta red social buscando pues
opiniones o posibles testigos o
considerando que un artículo que
escribimos tenga mucho impacto en
twitter significa que ha tenido mucho
impacto periodístico dice darnos cuenta
ahora que esta red social podría pasar a
manos totalmente de hilo en más debería
hacernos saltar las alarmas e intentar
pues eliminar no pasar un poco de esta
dependencia y que ya hay medios de
comunicación como el 'new york times' es
que han dicho a sus empleados que no es
necesario que tengan un usuario en
twitter y que de hecho los han alentado
a que pasen menos horas haciendo scroll
en esta red social vamos a ver entonces
qué va a pasar rosa difícil esto sobre
todo para nosotros los periodistas
que usamos twitter como una herramienta
para informarlos también pasamos ahora a
hablar del aumento las inclusiones de la
política israelí en la mezquita de
al-aqsa lo explica ruiz y va a fallar en
el mir el site exactamente está la
periodista explica que pues las
incursiones
judías no en al aqsa de lo que ya se
califica como pues a colonos israelí han
aumentado en los últimos años dice bueno
cabe recordar que al aqsa es considerado
como el tercer sitio sagrado para los
fieles musulmanes y que particularmente
para los palestinos este templo en
jerusalén esté en el jerusalén ocupado
es un símbolo de la existencia palestina
y que desde 1967 tienen lugar estas
incursiones que generan pues altos
niveles de tensión y de violencia contra
la población palestina que precisamente
la población palestina percibe estas
incursiones como parte del plan del
estado israelí para judaizar la ciudad y
destruir la herencia musulmana y
cristiana de jerusalén
otro lado los judíos israelíes ven estas
incursiones como el primer paso para
controlar pues a la zona y para dell y
de hecho para incluso destruir la
mezquita y construir encima lo que los
judíos consideran en la llama no el
tercer templo bien a lo que pasa es que
tal y como vemos en este gráfico estas
incursiones organizadas no por colonos
judíos y grupos de extrema derecha judía
pues las incursiones han aumentado pero
drásticamente pasaron de poco más de
cinco mil en 2009 a prácticamente 30.000
en 2019 antes de la pandemia explica la
periodista que antes estas incursiones
respetaban a los días sagrados del islam
pero que ya no es el caso como hemos
visto pues ha pasado este es estos
últimos días no de hecho ha habido ya
tres rights 3 como se dice redadas no de
la policía israelí en las que digamos a
compañía y protegía a estos colonos
israelíes en sus cursos es dentro de al
aqsa durante precisamente estos días de
ramadán que han coincidido este año con
la pascua judía
así es rosa gracias entonces por toda la
información de esta revista de prensa de
hoy lunes comenzamos semana pero nos
vemos mañana con más revista de prensa
pasamos a saludar a humanista con todos
los deportes rosas